hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space okay we just got
through a place of unimaginable horror
well actually it was like a dark room it
was pretty pretty unimaginable and I
actually ran out of mo this early on the
game that's not a good sign
oh yeah uh-huh
now I want to get in more than ever you
know you could have said that you know
something else now I really want to get
in there okay don't know how get this
grenade oh I'm just gonna do
ah I like his screams ha
I'm out here okay Titans station
conquering a moon plant cracking first
became feasible in the decades following
the discovery of the unified field
theory which allowed us to control the
graviton Gravitron in the same manner we
were accustomed to controlling the
electron with the advent of large-scale
applications of graviton control it
became clear to the mining consortiums
that they had a new tool at hand
Shaak point drives were in their infancy
so extrasolar mining was out of the
question and the dangers of planet
cracking were still unknown Saturn's
moon Titan was selected as the first
sight of the first moon harvest as it
was known back then Saturn was was as
far from Earth as the consortium's were
willing to work and still have
reasonable access to timely supplies and
support oh so they're on one of Saturn's
moons Titan so did they crack a moon
instead of a planet I can understand how
if you know you had this amazing tool
you'd be hesitant to completely destroy
a planet hey look it's a person hey
buddy how's it going you price you to
just kneel there oh you're only a dead
person okay
all right a way where my god done here
okay I need I need to store so I can get
some ammo
there are Necromorphs everywhere oh yeah
the entire sprawl affected mm-hmm how
this happen
the marker was destroyed you know I
destroyed you destroyed a mocker Isaac
Timon built another one on the station
why it's powerful a technology Oh
diamond once that you slam the rocket
it's still going to the trams my other
one
so not much animal oh I'm so gonna die
so good I just gonna have to like stasis
them and melee them to death
that's how pathetic I'm gonna be who
wants some huh fella loot someone was
playing the leave the loot is the
ancient or not ancient but Renaissance
version of the guitar some people here
Luton I think flute
nope was not give it up ah oh yeah Wow
grenade lunch in your face hahaha
one of these days they're jump scares
aren't gonna get me
oh why couldn't Isaac have been woken up
like a couple days before the whole
infection started that way could have
gotten some R&R oh okay
well holy [ __ ] what Oh
why would you say holy [ __ ] before the
explosion holy [ __ ] he's psycho
I mean shake it looks creepy Oh another
one
you want some ah here all spam I mean
kill you
Bozak like what the hell I thought this
was just something happened like my
grenade went out anyway
Guddu dude seems like a landmine grenade
how quaint I get all the goodies I blew
him the piece so should expect whatever
goodies they held with it
go scattering to the wind
the one over there that leg down there
there I'm looking around everywhere I
possibly can provide them because I know
that I'm gonna need them even eat just
about every message I am I going it's
locked
the conduit room I want to go in why is
it locked
oh oh oh I hear another gun my god it's
a goopy exploding any higher oh I think
it just said Oh another one
ah was that behind me I know you don't
get hot enough boom hope you give me
your goodies on door ah
hey your goodies about time gah hi I do
not like those let's go to duty but they
seem to be pretty stupid when it comes
to cornering me I'll always appear from
the opposite end of the room
okay oh wow
oh we can I move okay for sailors like
okay Isaac's still crazy still Crazy's
bold save yourself
wow there's like a whole nother level
hey baby I'm all nope take that take it
I was really cool like I've said before
the graphics and the effects are just
double what they were in dead space I
mean everything's are just a little bit
more colorful and the atmosphere is but
a bit better with the more pervasive
darkness those fire effects are really
good fire facts are one of the most
expensive resources in games to do them
right doesn't look bad I know they're
just young
it's probably just 2d sprites but still
well done anyway enough me geeking out
about stupid game I like I like
advancing some game edges i watch the
the showcases they have from all the
unreal engines i watch the valve source
engine updates religiously I love it
technology I'm a big giant eking dirt
like that oh back it's a bat you want
some grenades and that number land is
not right I pressed juice and it's the
bottom one fit it is warm
hahahaha that's perfect that's amazing
no no get off of this take it off of it
oh this that is an amazing weapon
okay the grenade launcher is definitely
one that I'm going to keep okay look at
this number laughs one is top that makes
sense - is bottom what three is to the
left
wha-ha-ha every note you know stays it
okay
okay it's just like a powerful gun that
all it is
I'll get the deal with the CIA other
than that it's a gun does Eva's oome Oh
does I telescope
okay anyway all right getting on this
train
oh I know from crime stranger bad rule
six of gaming role mom is elevators will
crash rule number two if the elevator
doesn't crash there's gonna be an enemy
that pops up rule number three is the R
inverse rule number one where it crashes
upward well number four is something
else will R 5 I forget my rules
rule number six trains always crash I
may be going look make sure I'm going
the right way
oh that one's tunnels things I need a
good gun line lime gun is cool because
if it can take out both legs or both
arms
Oh
on such an epic cracker concept bravely
best Oh me my crane spawn monsters like
that one
Oh where'd you let's go they didn't kill
you
kid me let them waste another you're
gonna stop ah
got ya [ __ ] give me that
I need to definitely be more efficient
about using these spikes come with oh no
you're not getting up
oh yes they beat something stomp aah
how'd you get there haha alright I I
died what what I died
oh nothing hit me I fine maybe I hit him
in the arm so it'd be better piccaboo
what the hell you're not dead
no way you're dead plug out of here get
you before you get up higher nope
hit hit him in the face hit him in the
wagon
oh no I died again haha okay fine I'm
just gonna go ahead and kill the other
one and then turn around because these
the two behind me appear cuz I'm bad at
this game apparently I'm just a little
rusty
just give me a sec oh what's that oh
cool no not today
very okay - you're behind me Thanks so
is this door open
honey oh yeah whatever
shut up shut up no yep yeah I hear em Oh
what was that I heard that Oh spit at me
Luz dary
get a spikey doohickey area that one
open yes open
or
anymore they won't want us to up huh
what I thought hello
okay that's bad
oh okay
Oh
mr. Burton Ariel knows something
Oh No okay go boom got ya
I take another one down with ya good
yeah good i lucky you can stomp much ah
I thought you uh ha took you out I
didn't even hit your arm in your arm
that's how good I am
and start that's not a good sign
why is it suddenly obeying Rafi now what
I I'm touched
wait I've wasted a mo oh I just always
wasted it
we're not goodies he's running from the
ceiling oh no oh no oh no oh no aah no
there you go
give me that goodie okay yeah credit so
really what I need right now okay
another one aah oh no aah
ed Oh get dead Oh No so bone I'm not
that guy got him Oh
Oh ah okay I don't know what killed me
something seemed to blow oh I I switched
to my grenade launcher oh crap oh you
know what I should do I should switch
the grenade launcher and just send out a
bunch of traps oh my god are you kidding
me you kidding me really did that just
happen
one there there there hope these aren't
too close to me I'm not gonna let you re
what I care Oh
ah no no no back I need to use that one
back
Wow where'd you come from gimme gimme
Oh give me something no there's too many
you didn't know fine gun long edge for
that take that take that with you nope
are you still that guy Wow
back to the cigarette
what is that a big guy did I just kill
him with one shot
II know suitcase with me
Wow oh shoot aw he's so strong
hang on this might be the most pleasant
route better don't get you dirty good
intelligence damn it
Timon has a signal again he moving
you're very important to my kid okay
very important to them who's them is
there a way to get that back
okay
it's the alternate fire maybe yeah yes
oh I love this gun so much I love it a
lot of this gun oh it's back here
power node okay all right that's
actually I'm over time that's all the
time I got for this episode thank you
guys so much for watching hope you're
enjoying it so far now it's awesome haha
except for all the times I died but
that's peace thank you guys so much for
watching as always see you in the next
part
bye bye